one of the things is not not falling too
in love or feeling too precious about
the material that you create
but really being open and willing to
find the you know and bold enough and
brave enough to find the very best
version of the story and that requires
when you were actively reading
screenplays how hard was it for you to
find a great screenplay
it it's always a challenge
it's funny i i just had um
i just had lunch on the weekend with an
executive producer a very popular tv
series and he reminds me that we met
back in like he was quoting me from 1989
like
who remembers that far back
and the thing he one of the one of the
things he remembered was me saying you
know i feel lucky if one out of a
hundred
gets me really excited
and i think that's for you know i don't
know if that's mathematically true but
it seems like that's the case
um and it's not because it's not always
because
the quality is not there or you know or
it's not always about the caliber of the
writing it's oftentimes because
for example me as a consumer
and as a producer
um i'm probably not the right guy to
write you know or to produce a um a big
sci-fi movie or certain other kinds of
affair there are certain kinds of
interactions or stories that really
appeal to me and many that don't but i'm
always writing to see
how talented someone is like how what
what kind of storyteller are they
but yeah i would say personally i'm i'm
not i've never been a volume producer
i've always been pretty fussy
but i would say if i find one out of 100
that's worth having a conversation to
see if there's a there there
if we get along if we agree about the
vision for the project if it's something
we want to
roll up our sleeves on together
it's probably about one percent
and that was going to be my next
question do you think that
we often hear that 99 of screenplays
written
are horrible
what's your experience
oh gosh
that's really hard to say 99 of
screenplay is written and that's a big
pool
usually by the time i you know
there's there's there's sort of a
natural
evolution
so
i'm really not taking scripts off the
internet or i'm not posting on public
forums saying send me your script so i
don't know what the big the bigger ocean
of opportunity looks like
i usually get scripts sent to me through
people who
are either writers that i know they're
representatives their attorney their
friend
someone in the business a producer
another producer might want to share
something with me
horrible's a horrible word
[Laughter]
um
certainly there are those that i read
where i go gosh this is way off the mark
there's i ca you know it's
it's i really want to root just like for
a movie same for a screenplay i i am
that guy who i'm rooting for the writer
i'm rooting for the story i want to love
this
if i read something that's so poorly
written that i just can't get through
the whole of it
that's as disappointing as it is you
know
like okay so it's not for me that's fine
but it's disappointing i want that to be
better i want that person to be better
to be a better at their craft
what do you think 99 of screenplays get
wrong
wow great question
i don't know if there's a
sort of that ubiquitous one thing that
they all get wrong
i just think that
one of the things writers
i would like to see more writers have
sort of a more systematic
reality check system inner circle system
so that
at a given point in time if they feel
it's ready for prime time they really
have a trusted group of not friends and
family but seasoned people people in the
business who know their stuff and how to
read a script
and get the feedback
i always do that to this day i still
i know that we get so close our our our
face is pressed up against the glass
we've been working on something for
seven or 12 or whatever number of
rewrites
we lose perspective
and if i were to give it to you and four
other people and you all come back with
one similar comment i know that i have a
real issue that i've overlooked
if all five of you come back with
criticisms but they're all different
that's a win
it's like okay now i can pick and choose
which ones make sense which ones do in
my gut i really feel enhance the story
i think so i think one of the things is
not not falling too in love or feeling
too precious about the material that you
create
but really being open and willing to
find the you know and bold enough and
brave enough to find
the very best version of the story and
that requires
i i hear a lot of writers talk about
well
um
i i really don't want to change it that
much you know it's no this is you know
that's be a painter be a sculptor
write a novel
this is a medium that's designed for
collaboration and i think you need to
take that as an asset as a positive and
invite it
because it's going to happen eventually
how many pages into a screenplay before
you know
it's a bad screenplay
not long
um there are many and and i sort of
agree
if someone doesn't grab me somehow in
the first three pages
with the quality of their craft or
something that's surprising in a good
way
that's that's what i'm hoping for
someone really putting a hook in my
mouth
but 10 pages in
easily 15 pages and you you sort of see
the caliber of the writing that the
the quality of the craft
um it's it's it's not likely that the
the actual quality of the writing is
going to shift on page 30 or 60.
when you sat down to read 3000 later to
be called pretty woman
where were you i was in
i owned a home in west hollywood it was
this absolutely charming 1920s bungalow
style classic hollywood bungalow right
all sunlight beautiful yard the whole
thing and
i had a room that was just like my
reading room it was a small like sun
room
uh and yeah that's where i did most of
my reading at night on the weekend
and
yeah i liked reed at home
as opposed to say at the office
so it was a friday night and you
i don't remember what day of the week it
might have been all i can tell you is i
was waiting with great anticipation uh i
had very high hopes because i was so um
admiring of jonathan and what i'd
what i knew of him as a person but
certainly what i'd seen on the page
and the only question was
could he really sort of jump it up to
that level of maturity and um
i promise you the moment he delivered it
to me i probably at that moment
wherever i was
turned off the phone if we had phones
that turned off whatever you know
metaphorically and it was like okay this
is the most important thing i have to do
this week i'm gonna go home and read
this
and so
three pages in you're loving it five
pages in
were you waiting for the other shoe to
drop
where you had notes and you thought this
isn't or you
no the thing about no i don't go into it
with that sort of lens
i'm not looking for what's wrong
um it's just not my way
when someone grabs me from the beginning
which he did
when
it's not heavy-handed it's just right
when that happens and i'm engrossed and
i'm invited into this and i'm he's got
me right
until he stops getting me
i'm not operating from here
right
and
that was from cover to cover that was my
experience i never really intellectually
assessed the script
that's why i was so excited about
because if i didn't i figure a lot of
other people won't
that they'll have an experience somewhat
similar to mine
where they're so engrossed in the
characters
the way it plays out in the dialogue and
and and all those other supporting roles
and and the friendships and
the tensions and whatnot that
they're um
to swim through the script the same way
i did
and that's what i pray for it's like
that's
that's the win
any tips you can give screenwriters that
would immediately improve their
screenplays especially in those first
few pages
i don't think there's any sage guidance
that i have other than to recognize what
you just said which is the opening of
your script is so important
you really want to set the table
right up front invite people let people
know what you're you're inviting them
into
um i've seen scripts that start out with
like
a page and a half or two pages of single
space narrative description
um
not a good way to start a screenplay
um to make us do that much work to get
to our characters or the action
so
um i would say you know really take
absolute advantage
and
um you know we're in the entertainment
business entertain me starting from
the first moment
but other than that i don't think i mean
every story is so uniquely different
not just because of the conventions of
the various genres but just
the storytellers are different and the
um
i can't i can't think of
it's really yeah never mind i'm rambling
it's it's just the recognition that you
that you bring up in your by way of your
question